in nine days long have I agree to it
nothing can prepare you
for the Star Wars the rise of Skywalker
the pg-13 it's too dangerous
I need to go alone we're all in this to
the end
we've got friends out there
good people will fight if we leave them
they've taken enough of us now we take
the war to them
that was fine all back
begin star wars the rise of Skywalker
video pg-13 get tickets now
let the final battle begin
we won't surrender
we make our last stand
starwars the rise of Skywalker get
tickets now
please pass Town Hall we know the
thousand generations live in you now but
this is your final
on December 20th
this saga
we'll end
[Music]
let us find all that all
again
starwars the rise of Skywalker get
tickets now right now
they fly now
confronting fear
the destiny of a Jedi
your destiny
[Music]
it's okay that we're here it's okay that
you're here's good
does she do that to us
our Wars the rise of Skywalker get
tickets now this will be the final word
in the story of Skywalker
[Music]
starwars the rise of Skywalker get
tickets now
you